vous aviez votre enfant qui vous
demandez l est c est ce que c'est cette
année au porno gradés juste qu'on lui
envoie par milliers je veux dire
recevoir aujourd'hui soit c'est ça n'est
pas le sujet lui descendre reviendrez
pour sa vaste demeure de la bgd vous
savez ce que vont dire les jo dan savage
pourront dire des téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent maintenant je vous dise
les body répondu tu nous tiens je vais
vous dire ce qu'ils m'ont dit elle elle
occulte le sujet dit la vérité je vais
dit que vous êtes en france et que vous
avez fait les contrôles pas du tout
goûté occulter le sujet une tout qu'est
ce que vous voulez savoir ce soir parce
que je vais vous expliquer ça râle a dit
klaus menacé je vis c'est moins vendeur
du rite et policières j'ai la police qui
est chez moi tous les jours j'ai dû
déménager en 24 heures d'accord avec mr
format fils hassan et l'autriche peut
tous non non attendez basse ni tout prix
à quitter sa sur votre plateau mettant
les nerfs de nabeul mais même lui
n'accepte pas un sale et menace de mort
j'en ai parlé avec lloris qui l'accepté
pas j'ai une chose à vous lire quand
j'ai supplié booba sur les réseaux
sociaux en exposant certes deux ou trois
menaces de mort que je recevais en
disant ma famille est en danger de mort
booba répondu noir sur blanc sur twitter
il vous aurait fallu d'y aller y aller
pour le savoir au plus tu aides